الان الى ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
والتطورات الميدانيه تحديدا في اقليم
دوناتسكو ومدينه وقد اجرى وزير الدفاع
الروسي ويجو زياره تفقديه للوحدات
العسكريه الروسيه في جنوب دنياسك قلت
الوزاره في بيان لها تفقد قوات او مجموعه
قوات الشرق في محور جنوب اثناء تاديه
عملها في منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
واضافت الدفاع الروسيه انها خلال زياره
لتقرير من قائد المجموعه وضباط مقر
القياده بشان الوضع الراهن يذكر ان
الوزاره لم تشير الى توقيت هذه الزياره
موقع ريبار ان القوات الروسيه تتقدم نحو
جنوب وان معارك عنيفه تدور قرب الطريق
الرابط بين بخموت
وكونسكا في المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه
للمدينه وكان يفديني بروجين مؤسس مجموعه
فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه قال ان مدينه
بخموت اصبحت محاصره بشكل شبه كامل وطلب
القوات الاوكرانيه بالانسحاب منها